hello there
people of the free internet it's me dave
rubin it's the reuben report direct
message for one
one one 21 and we're doing something a
little bit different today
in the first time first
time in all of history of the reuben
report i have never interviewed the same
person
back to back but that's exactly what's
happening today because there is a lot
of craziness out there
mostly related to free speech and big
tech and the rest of it and i sense the
person i'm about to bring on might have
a little announcement
and in case you're hearing birds
chirping in the background you might
have put it together already
congressman tulsi gabbard welcome back
to the reuben report long time no speak
thank you yeah lots happened since we
talked
we just talked like four days ago a few
days ago yeah
the whole world is completely different
first off it's just so perfect
you're out there in hawaii you've got
birds chirping behind you
perfect lighting this is like it really
you made the right move getting out of
politics you really did
i'm grateful it's uh yes i'm home here
in hawaii
uh the day started early but you know
my my work space is like the other half
of my laundry room that
that includes windows that hear the
birds waking up and talking to each
other
first thing in the morning so i really
have no complaints and it's a great
um reminder about you know
uh there's a lot of other things
happening in life that we should stop
and take a moment to appreciate
yeah most people are fighting with the
twitter bird all day long you've got
real birds out good ones so
definitely live in your best life okay
so you are going to make an announcement
in a few minutes but let's just kind of
talk about what's happened over the last
couple days because it actually is
relevant to the announcement that you're
going to make we know
that the social media bannings are going
through the roof right now
uh parlor was basically nuked by
uh the apple store and google play and
then amazon took their
servers down we're watching twitter
accounts be
obliterated what do you make of just the
general
tenor of what's happening right now we
can get into some of like the specific
stuff but just the general stuff like
literally i talked to you four days ago
we weren't talking about this
stuff and now it does seem like the
assault is on
you know people like you and i have been
talking about
the threat of these big tech monopolies
and the power
that they hold for a long time now
but i think given the events of the last
few days now
not only people across our country but
people in other countries leaders in
other countries
are saying hold on a second here this is
a very dangerous thing that these big
tech monopolies have such an incredible
amount of power that they can
completely uh cancel
censor or ban certain platforms or
individuals
from existing kind of on the internet
because it's hard to
hard to have a space if you can't talk
on twitter if you're not allowed on
facebook or if you can't have a youtube
account or
in in parlor's case um if you're not
allowed to host something on an amazon
server so i think a lot more people if
this is such a dangerous
situation that we're all being
confronted with and i think a lot more
people a silver lining would be a lot
more people are starting to become
really aware of how much power these big
tech corporations
have been building that's brought us to
this point where almost literally with a
click of a button
they can collaborate together and decide
nope
we don't want this platform or app or
person to be heard from
yeah you know it's kind of funny because
we talked like four days ago when i did
the intro here i only mentioned parlor
but the other thing of course is that
the president of the united states is no
longer on facebook twitter
they took him off spotify and pinterest
i guess he can't listen to music now or
post
uh his little cakes and things um
what would you have done if you were in
charge of one of these companies
what do you think a sensible policy
looks like because because at some level
i do
sympathize that they have to make these
crazy decisions right like if there's
people calling for violence
obviously you don't want that you know
me i would be as liberal with speech as
possible
but if you were in charge of twitter in
in the midst of this craziness what
would you do
about some of this fringe stuff
i mean i i think we have to look at the
law
and the law that is set uh
and protected by by the first amendment
so the
the example that's always given that's
most common is you know
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
uh
because that would clearly result in a
lot of uh
personal and physical harm to people in
the theater it wouldn't cite
that kind of uh you know rampaging
people get hurt
uh there are other examples that you
could point to but that's kind of the
barometer
barometer that um that we should use
that these corporations should use
in making decisions about which tweets
or which
posts uh could be a violation
of the law in that sense and uh
not be protected by our first amendment
rights
would you just would you just leave up
stuff as long as it basically wasn't
breaking the law would that
would that basically be the idea
yeah i mean it's like they're they're
outsourcing it seems to me that the
government is basically outsourcing
their decisions to tech companies and
that seems very scary right
yeah it's you know
whether by designer by accident the
power that these big tech companies have
been allowed to
amass is is a a pretty dangerous
thing in a democratic society in
particular
and the fact that even throughout the
events of the last few days that
we don't have we have to hear from you
know
angela merkel in germany saying this is
a really dangerous thing that is
unpressed an unprecedented threat to the
freedom of speech
we're not hearing that from many people
in our own government
at the highest levels which should raise
alarm bells
given our our society is is set up on
this foundation of fundamental freedoms
foremost among which is
that freedom of speech and uh again i i
think this
should be a cause for a lot of
introspection
amongst us as people but also in holding
our own leaders accountable saying how
can you support this
the thing that is always interesting to
me and that we i've seen
numerous examples of especially over the
last year is
how people uh you know like aoc and
others
support these actions but what happens
if you know jack leaves twitter and it's
taken over by somebody who holds values
different from
aoc and then the tables are turned and
they decide actually you know what
we don't want to hear what you have to
say you you hold views that we believe
to be
a threat to those that you know that
that are held by the
the corporate you know the c-suite
boards or whatever of these
these so the point being like the tables
can turn very quickly and that's really
the danger of this and when we talk
about free speech
we talk about free speech whether it's
speech that we agree with
or we don't agree with we have to stand
up in protection
of that freedom because if we only do it
for our tribe or our people or people
who we agree with
then we're really undermining that
freedom
overall yeah and of course you know
what's ironic when you talk about the
tables being flipped you know i'm
i'm more of a competition guy and it is
possible i always concede maybe these
companies
are so extraordinarily extraordinarily
large right now
that competition is sort of impossible
that's what parlor seems to be coming
against because of
this amazon thing but i kept saying all
along when people said trump needs to
regulate
trump needs to regulate i kept saying
well wait a minute if trump loses the
election
well he may be sympathetic to some of
your free speech stuff but the people
that you're about to bring in are not
going to be and then you're going to be
in a much worse situation
so you can make the same flawed argument
from aoc and
and the trump crowd at exactly the same
time all right listen i know you
are a busy lady with a lot going on with
those birds out there in hawaii so let's
shift
to what tulsi is doing next because when
i had you on last week
basically every comment in every forum
that i looked at was like
that woman should be running for
president again that woman
should be back in public office blah
blah blah blah blah
[Music]
i don't think you're going back to
public office just yet but you do have
an announcement to make what are you
doing chelsea
yeah you know it's it's in the line of
what we're talking about about the need
to uh come together as americans not as
democrats or republicans but the need to
come together as americans
and stand up to protect our freedoms and
our freedom of speech and encourage
civil discourse around issues connect
with each other as people
rather than as partisans
i've been looking for a great way to do
this and i'm glad that i connected with
you we're launching today
uh my platform on locals and starting
uh the tulsi community on locals
it's it's gonna be a great place to
hang out in hawaii we call it talk story
hey let's go talk story
which really is just like let's exchange
ideas let's share our stories with each
other let's get to know each other
better
and see how we can come up with great
ideas
constructive policies different things
that that we can do
both in our own ways as individuals in
our own communities in our own circles
but also
how we can work together to further
advance the ideas and values that that
are fundamental
uh to our country so uh it'll be a
i'm i'm excited about it because it'll
be a great place for
like-minded people to come together and
have these discussions hang out
you know i like to cook i know you do
too uh it's not going to be all
politics i don't think anybody can stand
all politics but
it will be a great place to share um
conversation
exclusive content i'll find my best
recipes and and
share a few with people every last my
most recent one was uh
a beautiful uh vegan miso shiitake ramen
and uh i i posted that on instagram and
people were like oh my god that looks
amazing share the recipe so it'll be a
fun place to gather together and have
some real conversation make friends hang
out
and uh be free from the concerns and
constraints that
a lot of us feel you know i i think very
carefully
before i put out a tweet because you
have to um
this will be a place where we can all
kind of just just relax a little bit
more and
and know that we are amongst friends
yeah awesome well i'm obviously thrilled
that you're part of it and just to be
clear so
the direct link of course is tulsi
tulsi.locals.com
and i just want to be clear for for
everyone watching this i
although i did start locals i have no
control over any of this stuff
tulsi it's her community we we just
basically built you the house
and now you go ahead and do whatever you
want in that house and have whatever
exchanges you want to have and post your
food pics and your
your search i sense there's going to be
some surfing videos
as well there has to be do you sense
that
generally that this will be the
direction the internet is going that
that's been my inkling for the last
couple years which is why i started
locals that the big tech thing
we went from too big to fail to too big
to succeed and i just felt you know if
we could just
treat the internet the way we treat our
own lives and that everyone can have a
house but you don't have to invite
everyone in your house to do whatever
they want that that to me seems like the
right way
is that is that kind of why you jumped
on board this thing besides me harassing
you about it for a couple weeks
no it's it's i think it is um it's it's
to me
especially i mean you you had foresight
and you saw this
perhaps a lot earlier the need for
something like this a lot earlier than
others
but again i think the events of this
last week like you have been having a
ton of conversations with
people who are really thinking about how
we can break through
and make sure that we have these not
just alternatives but really new
platforms that encourage
you know independent thinking and
freedom of thought freedom of speech
like who knew that such ideas would be
cutting edge in the world that we happen
to be living in today and something that
we actively have to
uh create platforms for and so
um i i do think that given what we are
seeing and the fact that
those the powers that be are not
recognizing the error
in their ways immediately uh just shows
that
i think there's going to be a lot of
hunger both on the part of participants
and contributors content creators
but also the the you know engineers who
are going to
really be uh going full speed ahead and
looking at
what other kinds of platforms can we
create that are
safe and i know for you we were talking
a little bit before
uh it's it's it's um it's tough you know
you the power of these these like three
or four big corporations
um and their control is
pretty um it's almost complete and so
um i know you could you could talk a
little bit about locals and just kind of
what you guys are thinking through and
how to make so i'm sure everybody who's
signing up or who's already members
want to know that locals is not going to
be the next parlor right
yeah well it's interesting because
there are massive technological issues
here because of these three or four
companies and that much control in so
little
so few hands is i think always dangerous
whether it's political
power or whether it's technological
control whatever it might be
um right now we are using amazon aws
servers those are the ones that that
were blown up by parlor
you know the interesting thing that
we've done is because anyone can join
right this moment and i hope you guys
will all do it
go to tulsi.locals.com join her
community
you'll be able to see everything for
absolutely free but you do have to pay a
couple bucks to engage in the content
and what we've found in two years of
doing locals which is now exploding
is that by just putting in a a little
bit of a pay wall whatever it might be
i think honestly if you put in a 50 cent
pay wall it would do it you eliminate
99.9 of the bad actors there's no bots
there's no trolls
and by the way tell us if someone joins
uh your
locals community and they're paying you
to hate you and
and just be mean and fight with
everybody you can kick them out of your
community but that's not an affront to
free speech because that's just saying
hey
you just can't do it in my community but
they can still be in someone else's
community or or you just profit off them
so it's like there are no perfect
solutions here
and for the record i actually want to
figure out a way to work
with the big tech companies you know
what i mean i think a lot of people
think oh we just have to blow them apart
now or destroy them and it's like
there's enough destruction in the world
right now i think there are ways and
i've already we're reaching out to the
people at amazon we're reaching out to
the people
at stripe we are also working on some
decentralized storage stuff and
other payment processors and all those
things it's like everyone wants the
solution right this second
i think we've done 95 of the work for 95
percent of the people
and then the tenor and the type of
discussions that will happen in your
community that that's up to you so in a
way i did drag you back into politics
because you're now the mayor
of tulsa.locals.com
yeah thank god there's not much
infrastructure cost there
yeah exactly well listen i know you have
a ton dude i'm seriously i'm i'm
thrilled and i'm actually honored that
you chose this platform because i i
think
it's just no doubt you are you are such
an important voice in everything going
on here and by the way
uh our first video with you that we put
up the other day was our fastest video
ever
to a million views it was the biggest
day of growth our youtube
channel ever had in terms of views and
that's not a coincidence it's because
a little honesty and decency goes a long
way so please guys check out
tulsi.locals.com
we're going to we're going to say i'll
let tulsi give a goodbye statement and
then i'm going to stick around for a few
minutes and talk to you guys about a few
other things
um but i'm just thrilled that you're
part of this thing and i look forward to
continuing the fight with you
likewise dave um appreciate it and again
look forward to
talking with you and and working with
you around these shared objectives of
just encouraging more freedom and
togetherness in this wonderful beautiful
amazing country and for everybody who's
watching that's the note i'll leave on
is
it's easy in the midst of moments like
this to kind of just get buried with
the the weight of the challenges that
we're up against and the powers that we
are up against but
we can't lose sight of just the pride
and the beauty of
of really what makes this country so
special and it is those fundamental
values upon which our country was
founded
and it's found in each of our hearts in
who we are as proud americans and so
there are
big and small ways that we can uh work
individually and together towards um
making that positive impact in our
country so let's channel this
frustration and maybe anger we have
let's channel it in a positive way to
come together stand together
engage in every way possible so that we
can work in a positive way to uh to a
much better place
amen and a woman i love it
all right have a good day dave nice
thanks tulsi all right tulsi.locals.com
uh guys i'm just going to hang tight for
a couple minutes just to
sort of unpack a little bit more of this
whole situation and everything that's
going on right now i know this is a
little bit different obviously than our
usual
direct messages we'll we'll get back to
the daily grind tomorrow don't worry the
news will still be here
i'm told trump's giving a speech a
little bit later today um there's
obviously a million
breaking stories all over the place and
there was a video that i wanted to play
this morning where uh joe biden gave a
speech yesterday
basically saying that when when we start
giving small businesses help we're going
to focus on black and brown and hispanic
and pacific islander
and blah blah blah it's like i actually
think that's against the constitution of
the united states
like shouldn't we be helping people who
need help regardless of their skin color
so
we'll we'll hit that tomorrow i just
want to say a couple other things about
the general censorship situation
and what's going on with free speech and
with locals and everything else
um we're in an extraordinarily uh
precarious moment
um there there's just no way to say it
more clearly
or um or non-hysterically like
this is this is serious stuff i have no
doubt
that this is now what's on your mind in
many cases probably more than covid and
more than any of the other
important issues of the day or what
happened at the capitol the other day or
anything else we have to figure out a
way to be able to communicate with each
other
and you know the irony of kovid by
locking everybody down
by keeping everybody in their houses and
all those things you said to people
okay your primary method of
communication will be our pipes right
it'll be
twitter and facebook and youtube and
everything else well now if we're gonna
systematically knock people off based on
political beliefs and and for the record
100 without any qualification i
absolutely condemn violence of any kind
political violence is wrong
period i have always been on the record
as saying that you're not allowed to do
it on locals
we're updating our terms of service at
the moment and obviously you can't break
the laws of the united states on any of
these platforms because that's a legal
problem you'd have then
with the government right so if you make
a violent threat on twitter
if you threaten to murder somebody on
twitter well it's not just that twitter
should kick you off it's that the
government now has evidence of
a violent threat and that's a you're
breaking the laws of the united states
but i've been against political violence
regardless of what side it's coming from
forever and that's why for the last
couple of years
as we've seen the violence out of antifa
and blm
and watched cities burn and what's going
on in portland and seattle and all of
these other places
that was lefty violence and it was
basically condoned or excused and
sometimes encouraged
by so much so much of the democratic
party so i am sort of pleased
i suppose that so many conservatives and
right leaning people are absolutely
condemning the violence
so i will always stand with people who
protest peacefully that is that is
basically the most important thing you
can do in a free society if you want to
keep it free
but you can't be violent so just to
shift this a little bit to what we're
doing with locals i obviously you know
i've been in this fight right like i'm a
youtube guy and a
free speech guy and this whole thing
like i've been in this fight for a
couple years for those of you that have
been following me for a while you you've
seen as i've made the moves to go more
and more independent
and not be with major networks
television networks
where i've had opportunities to do that
i was on patreon i didn't like some of
the things they were doing around free
speech and jordan peterson and i left
that was two years ago and that was sort
of the inception
of locals what i fully believe is that
the future of the internet will be these
small communities that you know we all
for the last 20 years
we got on these things we got on
facebook thinking that oh this is so
amazing it's going to connect us
with our long-lost friends and people
from
childhood and all of these things and
what it did then was
start showing us as the world became
oddly more political
that you disagree with a lot of people
and that's fine to disagree with a lot
of people but then because of the cover
of anonymity
and the cover of sitting at our
computers being able to type things to
people that you would never say to their
faces
it's all devolved into something that
that is
well we need only look in the mirror
right it's something about us
that that forces this to happen and what
i felt was
if i could protect my digital assets
meaning make sure that my videos and my
audio were safe and also build a place
where people would be more respectful
about the things that i care about then
that would be pretty great so we're
building digital homes
for people if you want a digital home
you should you should be on locals now i
want to be very clear about something
we have not solved all of the
technological issues and if you're
someone
right now if you work at google if you
work at amazon if you work at stripe
if you work at any of these companies i
want to figure out ways to work with you
right i am not sitting here saying i
want to burn the thing down i want to
figure out ways that we can all
be more respectful of who can be on
these platforms how we can all be more
transparent how we
there's no easy answer here you know i
know every time i talk about this stuff
i i see a lot of comments and people oh
you didn't solve the server problem yet
you didn't solve the storage problem yet
speech this okay we're working on all of
it i've got a great team of people we're
expanding it constantly and in the last
couple days
especially after what happened at
parlour two days ago trust me my phone
is melting because of the amount of
people reaching out to me trying to
figure out how they can be part of this
and how we can build it and how we can
fund it further
and all of those things and i also think
that that maybe something happened in
the last couple days
where people are going to start being a
little bit braver um
you know you may have seen the prageru
video that i did uh it was about two
years ago
was that i don't know what am i saying
it was it was less than a year ago
actually man
time is just weird in this covid time it
was we coordinated with the launch of
don't burn this book it was called the
bravery deficit
and i've felt along for a long time now
that the only thing that we need to fix
this is a little bit bright a little a
little bravery right to be a little bit
more brave i don't even consider myself
that brave i'm just telling you what i
think
i don't think that's such some great act
of bravery but i guess in this odd time
perhaps it is we can fix this
by all being a little bit better right
now so i want to
try to work with the big tech companies
but i
just fundamentally believe that the day
of the giant platform
is over the giant platforms are
dinosaurs
we we didn't know what we were doing
when we all got online
20 years ago we got on these things
thinking they were going to be great
and it's it's caused a situation where
you're starting to hate relatives and
fight with old friends
and have a have a psychotic mix of news
feeds
that show you baby pictures that make
you happy and then terrorist attacks
that make you sad and something else and
then
our whole thing our whole like like
cognitive way of being is getting
knocked out because of big tech maybe
it's partly by design
maybe it isn't and maybe it has much
more to do with just how humans have
behaved and evolved forever
anyway i i really really believe that
what we're building with locals digital
homes you build a home all we're doing
we're not giving you a big platform
we're just giving you the tools to build
a house
you build a house and you can put video
there you can put audio there
you have a news feed people can
communicate with you we have live
chat which is pretty awesome we're
working on live video streaming and a
whole bunch of other stuff
and as i said because there's a paywall
right
because there's a paywall you clean up
99 of the bad behavior my community's
existed for two years we've had no bad
behavior
there's no one threatening anybody on
there there's there's literally nobody
even being mean
in there but if you want to have a
community that's based in trolling and
silliness and poking fun at each other
then you create that too but you can't
break the laws of the united states
you can't post porn and you can't post
copyrighted content that's basically
what we've got so far
and again there is no perfect system and
if anyone's coming at you right now
saying they've got the perfect system
they just don't but i promise you and i
really hope that and i know that a lot
of people in tech watch this show
if you work at one of these big
companies we want to work with you we
want to figure this thing out like i
really think we can do it
and i think we've got the right idea so
if you haven't checked out locals
i guess i'm doing an infomercial today
but please do please do and even if
you're not going to join
my community there's a ton of other
great people on there greg gutfeld's on
there and now tulsi gabbard's on there
and scott adams is on there and carlin
borsenko's on there and michael malus is
on there and by the way it's not just
political if you're in if you're a
knitter if you're a
you got a basketball league if you're uh
you're an unboxer
if you like sharpies and you want to
create a group about sharpies go ahead
and do that i don't want this thing
to be political i started it so it sort
of feels political i suppose because we
we grabbed people out of my network but
every everybody like let's start making
networks
that are smaller and that aren't
dependent on big tech
like all right a certain amount of
people are always going to be into that
stuff they're always going to want to be
in the fight they're always going to
want to be
dealing with all that craziness but but
you don't have to be
and what i found on the reuben report
community actually which is pretty
amazing is people came
to the community because they wanted to
talk about politics or whatever
we end up posting as many food pictures
and dog pictures
and people post birthday pictures and
whatever's going on in their lives and
videos and all of that stuff
like it's all there and i think we've
actually started to build community the
way it's supposed to be so i think we
have to rethink community
we could do this guys but it's only if
you choose to be
to be part of it and i think we're
giving you the right tools to do it all
right
that's my infomercial for today i feel
like ron popeil and i've got spray on
hair
reubenreport.locals.com is my locals
community
tulsi.locals.com i have no doubt that
she's going to be doing awesome stuff
there oh and by the way because so many
of you are asking
so right now each community does have
its paywall which the creator sets
themselves
but we are working on a bundling right
because ultimately if you want to follow
20 people and everyone charges five
bucks that's 100 bucks a month
that's probably not sustainable for
everybody so we are working on a
bundling situation
there's a lot of sort of philosophical
issues with that and legal issues and we
want to make sure the creators are taken
care of
and some people obviously are way more
popular than other people so we have to
we're gonna figure it out again i'm not
trying to over promise here we gotta
we gotta figure that stuff out we're
gonna continue refining the
uh the terms of service and and we're
gonna continue
trying to innovate and and do
storage and serving and the rest of it
in in a really cutting edge way and
we've got a great team and i'm super
proud of it and we've got
incredible investors oh and i'll just
say one other thing you know
when i started doing this two years ago
and we were building the company and i
would go into a lot of the big tech
offices
and talk to a lot of these people what i
noticed is nobody had a problem with our
idea
literally nobody everybody was like yeah
of course that's the idea that everyone
should be doing
everybody said that like nobody said oh
no no no this idea is just terrible
what everyone said basically the people
who didn't end up working with us said
was oh well i don't want to do something
political i don't want to do something
about free speech
and these were people who were often
libertarians privately or
you know not all like wokesters right
and that's what i'm talking about the
bravery thing it's like we need if we're
going to fight this thing
as a society we need venture capitalists
to be part of it we need regular folks
to be part of it we need
we need everybody in every corner
whatever corner of the world is your
expertise is your thing we need you
to figure out a way to to make this
thing better and i think we can do it so
locals.com create a community
of people that you want to be around and
if you and if some people are in your
community doing things you don't like
then you boot them
and as i said if they're doing illegal
things we're not going to keep them
there and they'll be in trouble with the
united states government
i think we can fix this guys it's my
little salvo into it you know
i live in a world of talk and one of the
things that frustrated me over the last
couple years
is that everyone just talks right there
are more podcasts than people at this
point i'm pretty sure
i think i made that up but but it might
be true there are so many podcasts
everyone's always talking about
everything and no one does anything
about anything
so i did something here i've put a lot
of work into this thing
in many ways at some level now more of
my
day is spent working on locals than it
is on on reuben reports stuff
it's a chance it's a chance i don't know
how many people are offering you a
chance so
locals.com my communities
reubenreport.locals.com
tulsi.locals.com and there's just a
whole bunch of other great people and
let's just keep thinking about these
things and by the way you can
because we have a news feed and
everything you can communicate with me
directly there i'm not responding to
people i'm really going to stop
responding to people on twitter
i don't respond to people on the other
platforms anymore
but i do respond to people over there so
if you want to get ideas across we've
hired
several of the employees at locals were
were fans of mine and people that
watched the show and we've hired
developers and onboarding people and
everything else
we just got some new investments so
we're continuing to hire jobs at
locals.com if you want to send us an
email if you're
if you're a developer if you've got a
just you know you're an onboarder you're
in sales whatever it might be
we're gonna try to figure this out let's
do it together i think i made my point
have a nice day